لذا ، إذا انتخبت الكلية الانتخابية
الرئيس المنتخب جو بايدن ،
فلن تغادر هذا المبنى ، لذلك
بالتأكيد سأفعل ذلك بالتأكيد وأنت
تعلم ذلك ،
لكنني أعتقد أنه سيكون هناك الكثير من
الأشياء التي تحدث بين الآن و
في شهر كانون الثاني (يناير) ، تم العثور على الكثير من الاحتيال على نطاق واسع
،
فنحن مثل دولة من العالم الثالث ، كما
تعلمون ، من
المعتاد أن يذهب الرؤساء السابقون إلى
تنصيب الرئيس التالي ،
ولا أريد أن أقول ذلك ومع ذلك ، أعني
أنني أعرف الإجابة.  سأكون صادقًا ، فأنا
أعرف الإجابة ولكني لا أريد أن أقولها
ولكن
يبدو أن شيئًا كهذا ربما
لم يحدث أبدًا من قبل ، لكن ربما
لم يمسكه الناس ولكننا اكتشفنا ذلك.
لقد حصلت على مئات
الآلاف من الأصوات ،
اسمع ، عفواً ، عندما لا
يسمحون لمراقب الاقتراع الذي هو شخص مقدس
في بلدنا ، الناس لا يعرفون ما
هو مراقب الاقتراع ، فهو يعتبر مقدسًا
في بلدنا  عندما طردوهم
من الغرفة
هذا ليس صحيحًا بالتأكيد ، وعندما
وضعوها في أقلام ،
أعذرني ، لم يفعلوا ذلك ، لم يعترف المحامون
بأي شيء